♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
In a speech last week at the
Volvo truck plant in Maryland,
President Biden said, quote,
"Let me start off
with two words --
Made in America."
[ Laughter ]
And then it only got worse when
he said, "Sorry, I meant four."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden announced
last week that he will pardon
thousands of individuals
convicted
of simple marijuana possession
and said, quote,
"No one should be in jail just
for using or possessing
marijuana," because after all,
if you smoke enough marijuana,
your couch is the jail.
[ Laughter ]
Russian President Vladimir Putin
convened a meeting today
of his national
security council.
There were no survivors.
[ Laughter ]
Treasury Secretary
Janet Yellen
said in an interview yesterday
that OPEC's decision
to reduce oil output will harm
the global economy.
It's what OPEC is calling
"the point."
[ Laughter ]
At his rally in Nevada over the
weekend, former president Trump
claimed that, quote, "Two years
ago, everything was so good
in our country, and now
it's going to pieces."
Man, I can hardly remember.
I mean, what was happening
2 years ago?
Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, those were --
those were good times.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A federal judge in New York
last week issued a ruling
that blocked several parts
of a new state law
that banned guns in sensitive
areas like museums, stadiums,
and Times Square, because
everyone knows the only way
to stop a bad guy with a gun
is a drunk Elmo
with nothing to lose.
[ Laughter ]
The NFL announced over
the weekend that it will update
its concussion protocol,
and then in a troubling sign,
they announced it again.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
26% of Americans believe
there should be a minimum age
requirement for getting
ears pierced, while over
in Jersey, there's a Claire's
in the maternity ward.
[ Laughter ]
That was my favorite one,
I got to acknowledge.
Today was former NFL quarterback
Brett Favre's 53rd birthday,
and even his cake was stolen
from needy children.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, did we ruin his birthday?
And finally, after a video
gained attention online
of a woman in a bikini getting
out of a city fire truck
in front of a strip club,
the mayor of San Jose
announced last week than an
investigation has been launched.
And the only way they're getting
away with this
is if that woman was stuck
in a tree.
[ Laughter ]
Shot that in Central Park today.
She was great.
♪♪
-White House officials are
reportedly planning
to downplay President Biden's
upcoming 80th birthday.
Well, good luck with that,
because everything about Biden
screams "birthday week."
[ Laughter ]
[As Biden] Monday, I'm going
bowling with my college buds,
Tuesday's shots,
Wednesday's Dave & Busters,
then we're all flying to Ibiza.
[ Laughter ]
[Normally] President Biden's
granddaughter, Naomi,
is set to get married
next month at the White House.
Though if you're trying to make
people forget how old you are,
maybe don't advertise
that your granddaughter
is getting married.
[ Laughter ]
According to a newly-obtained
audio, House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy told two police
officers in a private meeting
that former president Trump
didn't know that his supporters
were attacking the Capitol
on January 6th,
and the only possible way I
believe that
is if he didn't know
this was the Capitol.
[As Trump] I thought it was
a Medieval Times.
I thought it was
[ Cheers and applause ]
[Normally]
Election Day is four weeks away.
Said Biden, "Uh, well, then
we're also giving everyone
in jail for weed 40 bucks."
[ Laughter ]
Elon Musk discussed
his estranged daughter
in a new interview and added,
quote,
"I have very good relationships
with all of the others.
Can't win them all."
Hell, some people can't even
count 'em all.
[ Laughter ]
The Northeastern University
School of Law
mistakenly sent acceptance
e-mails recently
to nearly 4,000 applicants.
Even worse, Harvard Law
accidentally sent
an acceptance e-mail to someone
whose dad didn't even go there.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according to a new
ranking of fast food chains,
Chick-fil-A has the slowest
average drive thru experience,
while the fastest
drive thru experience
is McDonald's when
all you order is ice cream.
"Yeah.
One ice cream cone, please."
"Sorry it's broken."
"Bye."
♪♪
-President Biden was interviewed
last night by CNN anchor
Jake Tapper, and not as he was
expecting, Walter Cronkite.
[As Biden] Oh, you must be
the new kid, huh?
[Normally] President Biden said
in a new interview
that he doesn't think
that Russian President
Vladimir Putin will actually use
nuclear weapons,
though I don't think
it was a good idea
to add
[imitates chicken clucking].
[ Laughter ]
In the same interview,
President Biden said
he doesn't expect the US economy
to enter a recession,
but added that if there is one,
it will be, quote,
"very slight."
You can watch the entire clip
in a GOP campaign ad in 2024.
Buckingham Palace
announced yesterday
that King Charles' coronation
will take place next year
and said that the event
will be, quote,
"Rooted in long-standing
traditions and pageantry."
You know, the things
that drove his son
and daughter-in-law completely
out of the country.
The Senate recently held its
12th annual bipartisan luncheon,
which featured more
than 560 pounds of barbecue
and I'm guessing
at least ten paramedics.
According to the latest numbers,
The Netflix series
"Monster: The Jeffrey Dahmer
Story" has been viewed
more than 700,000,000 hours
since its release.
So get ready for NBC's
newest series, "Chicago Dahmer."
[ Laughter ]
That's right. The
Jeffrey Dahmer Netflix series
has been viewed more than
700,000,000 hours,
I guess because it was slightly
less horrifying
than "The Great British
Baking Show's" Mexican Week.
[ Laughter ]
"It's too much for me.
So we go back to 'Dahmer?'"
And finally, a winner was
declared yesterday
for the annual Fat Bear Week
contest.
Said the winner, "Wait, I
thought it was just bear week."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
The House January 6th Committee
voted unanimously today
to subpoena former
President Trump.
I would say this is big news,
but it's really more like
putting one more parking ticket
on that van that's been
on your block for a year.
That ticket ain't getting paid.
According to a new report,
when former president Trump
received a subpoena
earlier this year
for any classified documents
taken from the White House,
he told an employee to move
boxes to his personal residence.
Man, he is a bad criminal.
You're supposed to get rid
of the evidence.
Trump is the first criminal
to plant the evidence
on himself.
[ Laughter ]
"This weed? No, I'm not holding
this for a friend.
I bought this with my money."
A jury in Connecticut yesterday
ordered conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones to pay
nearly $1 billion
to the families affected
by the Sandy Hook shooting.
So I hope he got paid
really well for his work
as the Mucinex guy.
[ Laughter ]
The FDA announced yesterday
that it has authorized
the Omicron-targeted coronavirus
vaccine booster shots
for children as young
as five years old,
which is great news if you're
a parent of young children
or think that you might be.
[ Laughter ]
Producers for LeBron James's
talk show, "The Shop,"
announced yesterday
that they will not air
an upcoming episode
with Kanye West
due to his use of hate speech.
Because once they
edited it all out,
this is what
they were left with.
-So...
And...
-That wasn't that bad.
That wasn't that offensive.
A few edits
and that was just,
I think, what all of us
were thinking.
A man in Idaho recently broke
a Guinness World Record
for longest duration
balancing a guitar on his chin.
Even more amazing,
he managed to keep it on there
the entire time he was
being kicked out of the party.
[ Laughter ]
Meta -- Meta this week launched
its most advanced
virtual reality headset ever,
which costs $1,500.
They're so advanced,
you'll completely forget
that your wife left you.
[ Laughter ]
The car company Rezvani has
announced the new $250,000 SUV
called The Vengeance,
which has options
for body armor,
explosive protection,
and night vision.
So come hell or high water,
your kids will get to soccer.
[ Laughter ]
Today was National No Bra Day.
So looks like Biden
hasn't undone
all of Trump's
executive orders.
[ Laughter ]
Dunkin Donuts recently changed
its customer loyalty program
from DD Perks
to Dunkin' Rewards,
and I can only assume
it's because they were sued
by a 1980s porn star.
[ Laughter ]
Happy No Bra Day, Dee Dee.
And finally, the Social Security
Administration
announced today
that recipients will receive
a cost of living adjustment
next year of 8.7%.
So get ready for that to trickle
down to your $5 birthday checks.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
♪♪